sit here and say you're gonna let's make it happen. Let's make
it happen.
Hi. Come on.
They come and say like probably, "Hey, it's the middle of the
night. The This is This is the person who's going to beat Zena
fight." Okay. Security shows up. Imagine it's not even the cops,
but security shows up and this is the This is the energy switch.
Okay. Hi,
bro. Imagine if Zena was doing this rant. The energy she'd have
for security if they showed up.
The content police
angeling for a job clipboard in his hand while Kelly's just
uh Trump decided to straight up drop an uh an Fbomb today. Okay.
What the Iran violated the peace agreement in the So apparently
people were accusing Iran of violating the ceasefire.
Do you believe that Iran is still committed to?
Yeah. They violated, but Israel violated it, too. Israel is committed.
Israel, as soon as we made the deal, they came out and they dropped
a load of bombs the likes of which I've never seen before. The
biggest load that we've seen. I'm not happy with Israel. You
know, when when I say, "Okay, now you have 12 hours. You don't
go out in the first hour and just drop everything you have on
them. So, I'm not happy with them. I'm not happy with Iran either.
But I'm really unhappy if Israel is going out this morning because
the one rocket that didn't land that was shot perhaps by mistake
that didn't land. I'm not happy about that. You know what? We
have We basically have two countries that have been fighting
so long and so hard away. Damn.
Damn. has sent sent you the Muppets. Damn. Yeah, I got it. I
got it. Where is Okay, I'll fix it right now.
Howard just dropped one more time. I'm not happy with them. I'm
not happy with Iran either. But I'm really unhappy if Israel
is going out this morning because the one rocket that didn't
land that was shot perhaps by mistake that didn't land. I'm not
happy about that. You know what we have? We basically have two
countries that have been fighting so long and so hard that they
Discord site is not working. So, GG. I tried, Kelly. I can't
I I appears I can't upload anything. What the heck? No. Is it
just Yeah, the the reactive Discord is just broken right now,
unfortunately. So, I can't I can't set that up for you right
now. Soon, soon.
Wild talking about Israel and he dropped the fbomb. I mean, is
he really talking about Israel at all? Antonio Brown has apparently
fled the country. Guys, if you remember, Antonio Brown was the
guy who fired shots
at the Aiden Ross boxing event. Former borderline Hall of Fame
NFLer. Okay, this guy almost certainly could have made the N
the Hall of Fame. This guy was a prolific, like the best wide
receiver in football for like five years in a row. And
he is
so lost. He says, "I'm out of I'm out the country. Ain't no more
child support. Tell your mama get a job." Damn. Damn.
That about his own kids.
Yeah, he's definitely bragging about being a deadbeat dad right
now. Dear
Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. That's
Oh, not cool. Not cool, Antonio. Not cool at all. What the hell?
Not even borderline. If he wasn't mentally ill, he'd be in. Yeah,
he's like I'm saying he's borderline first ballot and I think
there was still like a glut at wide receiver, but he he was just
like the best in football for like and like it wasn't close at
all. The other crazy thing is I don't think he got lit the up
like yeah, okay, the perfect hit was bad, but I don't think he
he usually didn't get like lit the up. He was a really crisp
route runner. He never I I don't think he got caught squarely
all that much, right? It had to be Yeah. Well, it had to be like
the perfect hit. People basically had to catch him like in the
process basically. Like if he's going up for a catch. Uh yeah,
if he's going up for a catch, you'd have to hit him before he
had the ball. You guys disavow him. I don't know, man. If he
was a receiver for my team, I'd probably have a hard time. He
certainly won me a lot of money in fantasy football. This guy
was I played PPR leagues. This guy was like a number one pick
like multiple years for me. People just wouldn't pick him and
then I'd get him and then he'd just be like the highest scoreer
in the league. Okay. Easy, easy points every time. He was out
of his mind. Anyway, all right. Being a deadbeat dad in 2025
is embarrassing. Is he naked? I don't think he's naked. No, this
is like a bronze statue of him or something. Is him is a bronze
statue with a massive bulge.
Apparently, apparently they decided to do that. You cannot call
him a dead beat dab when you don't even cover how much he was
required to pay. Uh, yeah, I can. He literally just said He literally
just said, "I'm not paying you money." That's not I don't need
need to know how much he was ordered to pay. She's just like,
"I'm not paying you anything." That's a dead beat dad. Massive.
I mean, okay. Noticeable bulge. Pants are like struggling to
contain. Yay is paying half mil per month. That's probably appropriate.
How would it not be appropriate for Yay to pay a half mil per
month? Wouldn't that be That just sounds appropriate to me. Kim's
got money. That is ridiculous. No, it's not. Kim's got money.
They both got money. Kim's not getting like insane money from
him. It's just it's literally like you're covering about half
of the kid's expenses. That's basically all it is. Why do we
pretend it's something else? A child did not cut does not cost
that.
Kim Kardashian and Kanye West child cost that much to raise.
Kim Kim don't need the money, bro. That's like so he can cover
half of the expenses for their kid. I guarantee you they go to
the best private school in the USA or some [__] and
they go on trips all the time and they've got like insane designer
clothes that Kanye would want them to have, right? Code Maxer.
Yes, but that child is growing up with privilege either way.
That child should be growing up with privilege. That's like that's
like the bare minimum for Kanye to be spending. It's insane if
you don't understand that. Why send his son? Well, I don't think
it's his son, right? It's his kid. I I I thought his kid I thought
he had a girl little girl with Kim. Am I crazy? Play the merk
clip. Oh, I didn't do subreddit review. True.
No, there's a bunch of stuff in the subreddit that I probably
wanted to look at, right? I think I think there's a bunch of
stuff. I grabbed this to actually watch. Uh what is this? There's
an aristocracy 8 minute 30 second aristocracy clip. God, don't
be bad. Don't be that bad. Casey Trump chatters. I saw Kelly
pop up in my city's Bumble. Ask Kelly if she's single. Are you
guys okay? Uh, no. They're not okay. That's probably why they're
chatting like that. Doesn't sound like they're okay, Kelly. It
sounds like they're kind of crazy to me. Sounds like you're getting
catfished.
Sounds like they're not doing well out there. Okay.
All right. We're good to go. Onto content for today. So, there's
a couple space ghost clips. Uh, I'll do the space ghost clips.
I'll do We'll go space ghost. We'll go into what? Merk off the
park. probably quite a bit of this stuff. We can we can just
roll through a couple of these right off the bat. So, this is
uh Casey Tron. Bro, Casey Tron's been a little bit funny. Okay,
as as gross as Casey Tron is, she's been a little funny. She
I She knows like once you understand her only goal is to upset
people. It's like, oh well, she's actually quite good at it.
I'm sorry. She's been quite good at it, right? She's kind of
like she kind of really funny when she's just people off. Yeah,
degenerate pads me too. Uh, green screen probably. Oh, Casey
Tron takes shots at Destiny and DJers during Ethan lawsuit response.
Like I understand that like like it's like there's a lot of people
that I don't like too, but I don't think that they're like I
don't think that they deserve to be locked up and have their
entire life ruined,
you know? Like, you know what I mean? Yeah, I know what you mean.
I know exactly. Besides Destiny, I do think he should be locked
up. I swear to God, I didn't know I was pausing at that exact
moment. That's Wait, but also true. But also true. So Oh, so
good. So good. And if you're a fan of Destiny in here,
um, like, leave me alone. You guys have been harassing me for
5 years.
Like, has it been more than 5 years now? Like, oh my god, I'm
so sorry that I clock destiny being a sociopath like 5 years
before anyone else.
Like, why am I being attacked? Like, you can like even his viewers
know he's a sociopath. Like, even the fans of him know he's a
sociopath. Like, I'm so sorry for clocking the truth. Like, you
guys can stop harassing me now. It's been 5 years. Only five
more years. And not We'll get there, too. Only five more. Steven's
like really good. Like really, really good. Guys, let's take
Okay, what is this one? This one is We probably did see this
potentially. Okay, it's sloppy. It's this was a hit piece. Pisco
reacts to Ethan's lawsuits. I'm I'm going to check it out cuz
um I do think we watched this. This will update Kelly a little
bit in case you didn't catch this. Back an even bigger picture.
The notion that, and this is not even disputable at this point,
that H3 is acting like a savior for the fair use community, the
reaction community is so preposterous.
Yeah. As to be insulting to my intelligence.
They're calling Pisco a socialist now. Yeah. Full of hell. I
don't know if you caught it. We did that was the I think one
of the last segments I did was just going over some of the people
responding to Pisco and Lykan and like Straighter Aid streams
with Pisco a decent amount. I think they do like reacts to random
content together, right? They'll both fire up their stream. They'll
both stream like a react together which is cool, but I think
people are like, "Oh, well actually he does content with Straight
now, so he's a socialist." And it's like one, I'm pretty sure
his existing partner was already pretty left-leaning. Okay. So,
like if you're going to just say Pisco's by like a woman, you
could at least say his actual partner's name who's very po who's
like does politics on her own, has like a channel with like a
bunch of big videos on it, tons tons of subs, right? Like, if
you're going to say that, you shouldn't even give it to Straight
Raid for one thing, but people do. And it's like it's just clearly
when they say that it's clearly just DGers who are like mad about
straight raid and Lykan because that's the only reason you would
think that. Yeah. It's because Yes. It's because he's criticizing
H3. Absolutely. Yeah. And I believe it actually is a bit of disingenuousness
to start off with this broader concern about the quote injustice
regarding these kinds of streams that basically steal content
and don't transform the nature of the content at all or provide
any commentary.
to start with that view to show XQC be one of the prime suspects,
one of the biggest purveyors and then to try to distinguish and
say this is really about helping the reaction community to prevent
a kind of a lawsuit from which by the way is the first line of
the Denim's lawsuit, right? That this is to meant to prevent
lazy reacts, but that's not what he's trying to do at all. It's
not even remotely what he's trying to do. From Disney or Sony,
that is so disingenuous and it's just false. It doesn't pass
the smell test at all. I resent it. Yeah, it's Oh, thank you.
Yeah, it's gross. It's gross. You're gross. And then second point,
the complaint's unhinged. You have a strong case. Just present
the case. Don't be a loser idiot. Hire some lawyer who either
doesn't know what he's doing or
you're telling him to do this kind of unhinged.
It's sloppy. Tons of typos, formatting errors. It's impossible
to read. It's [__] So if you really cared about protecting
the reaction community, you wouldn't use that filing, dude. You
wouldn't do that. Filled with venom, filled with, you know, not
getting to the facts, not getting to the point. This was a hit
piece in the form of a legal filing. And maybe even it's even
true on some base accusations. But don't pretend you're here
for the broader reaction community when you file that piece of
you're not doing anyone any help. You don't think anything would
settle with a symbol of public apology of what? Hold on. Um,
the code max guy, you're really dumb. You're going to like actually
trigger me. The reaction community. You can't say the reaction
community when your number one defense of your lawsuit is I'm
trying to help the reaction community. And the the point of the
criticism is Ethan is a disingenuous loser.
Like, we're calling him disingenuous. We're pointing out the
obvious problem of him saying he's protecting the reaction community
while not taking steps to do that. And then people are like,
"Well, the reaction community." I Okay, then you should also
call Ethan Klein a disingenuous loser. Thank you. Cool. I'm sorry
for what? That's the question, right? And it's the it's a great
question, right? What is What are they sorry for? What does Ethan
want them to be sorry for? He doesn't want them to be sorry for
Thank you for the membership. He doesn't want them to be sorry
for copyright infringement. That's not what's going on here.
And you have to be very like naive to think that that's what
they would want apology for. I'm sorry for stealing your video.
XQC stole your video. He's not actually mad about that. He's
mad about these people because of who they are, not what they
did or what they did. Is the reaction community malicious? Not
a relevant point because it's not the first line of the lawsuit.
The first line of the lawsuit is about protecting the reaction
the the community, the commentary community from lazy reactions
causing like a a downstream effect. That is the first thing on
other stuff, not this. That's it. What do you want to say? Earth
is the answer to the question. That's it. That's it. All right.
Cool. Okay. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. So, there's an Aerys
clip. We will watch the Aerys clip first. I'm going to watch
this Merc clip cuz Riyle wants me to watch the M clip. I'm going
to you I'm going to you. So, this is
M. By the way, disavow. Totally. This is MK talking about Zena
apparently. So, you know what? You know what? That's fine as
long as I get my if that's fine as long as I get my hands on
you. that I will get my hands on you and I will finally teach
you a lesson. Dena, I'm on I'm on some real I'll you up
talking about Oh, I'mma stab you. I'mma You ain't doing You Zena.
Okay, I will say Ry, when you when you want to upload these things,
I don't know if this works. I get I get what you're cooking.
I get that you're trying to do the um you want to pass. I think
if you also put text up, text will get analyzed by YouTube anyway.
So, you probably won't get through sensors,
right? YouTube scans all text on screen and parses it. And if
you have a whole bunch of profanity on stream or on screen, it's
not going to work. So, your bleeping is like kind of pointless
in the first place. I don't post this on YouTube. Are you crazy?
Then why do you have it all censored?
I'm just saying I get Okay, I get why it's censored. Maybe if
you want me to watch it on Twitch or something, but I'm just
saying that like the censorship might not make as much sense
if you're not going to push it and with the text. I don't know.
It's fine. I your man and you're up about it. I on your man.
He my
Oh my god. I Why would you brag about that? Gross. She just said
She just said
pissed on. Okay. Sidonia is moving away from the Twitch chat.
Guys, don't forget twitch.tv/jlk
with an underscore. We're live on Twitch as well. All right.
Oh my god, that's where we are. We're over there. We're uh Hold
on.
H3 lawsuit coverage. Sorry, I need to do better better titles
on Twitch, I think. But guys, don't forget about the Twitch,
okay? We're over there. We're on both. Mick is so dumb for this.
She knows she can't fight. Well, she's saying that she in Dar
Darius's mouth, which is kind of up. Okay. I don't know why you
would out that detail. That seems like like you're not even hurting
Zena the most. You're kind of hurting Darius. You're outing a
thing about Darius. What are we doing here? I your man and you're
up about it. I on your man. He drank my you. Oh my god. I
on your man and he drank my You stupid You
You're mad because your man drank my You're mad because this
is very gross. Your man drank my He drank my
Your man drank my Your man drank my You Your man drank my Yeah,
he drank my And you're mad. You're mad.
Your Your man drank my Your man drank my Your man drank my You
stupid. Yeah, he I just kind of She needs to She needs to up
the variation a little bit. I I feel like after the 10th time
it doesn't hit quite as hard. Okay. I I ho I literally stood
over his face and I all over him and he drank my stupidies.
What? Dude, you you can see her you can actually see her reliving
the moment like as she talks through this. You can see it in
her eyes that she is reliving that moment of like looking down
on Darius and just like, "Yeah, I
literally stood over him." She's like she can see him. She's
projected him in her mind onto the ground there. Okay, which
she can do cuz she is like 3 ft taller than Darius. All right,
Darius was standing full up beside her and she still did this.
Okay, that's how much taller Murk is than Darius face and I all
over him,
dude. The the eyes like just Oh, this frame this frame right
here goes like hard. if it wasn't blurry. Uh, they all go hard
all over him and he drank my
Okay, it's not it's not a funny it's not a funny comment most
of the time, but when it comes to the TTS at that perfect moment,
okay, it is funny. The only thing I want is to give your ass
a black eye is to put my hands on you. And I have been begging
and begging and begging and you know what? Oh, I'm going to you.
I'm going to you. So, you know what? You I'm sorry. M is like
way bigger than Zena. Okay. Way way bigger than Zena. Ain't nobody
on planet Earth taking Murk in a fight if they actually get in
any physical altercation. There are zero people on the planet
of Earth who would take Murk over Zena in a fight. Okay. I think
she got punched the other week, didn't she? Merc. Yeah. Yeah.
Zena is like a honey badger. Okay. You just you would not you
would not bet on you know what that's fine as long as I get my
if if you me you me that's fine that's fine that's fine as long
as I get my hands on you but I will get my hands on you and I
will finally teach you a lesson because your
sits on the internet talking about all these people you need
to be taught a lesson you need to be taught that you can't just
sit here and say all this without getting with getting away with
it you're not going to get away with it and you're not going
to get away with it I have been begging Begging and begging and
begging. It's your karma is coming for you. You will finally
learn a lesson. Whether or not I die, whether or not you get
this money, that's fine. As long as I get my This is just some
crazy fanfiction fantasy. Okay. Shower arguments.
Hands on you because you're not getting away with this. You are
not getting away with it. I don't give a I don't give a if I
lose my KCIP. I don't give a You You literally sat here and begged,
"Oh, no cameras. Uh no police. No, this, no that. I don't give
a I will, Zena. I'm telling you right now, I'm going to get my
hands on you. That's why I in your man's mouth and I'll in his
mouth again
his mouth every Let's be real. That's probably true. It's probably
true that she will do it again. Like, let's be 100% honest with
ourselves, with everybody. That's almost certainly going to happen
again. Single day of my life. And he liked it, too. And he drank
that.
I all over him. And guess what? Guess what? Guess what? He drank
my you.
Yeah. Is this the same clip or like It's not. It's not. She just
keeps saying it over and over and over again at the camera.
Over and over. It's We're only halfway through the clip and it
feels like too many, you know.
I will you up. Come over right now. Come over right now, you
stupid. I in your man's mouth. He drank He drank my urine.
Why would anyone brag about this? I just I in your man's mouth.
Cry about it. You I don't know.
I What's up here? In your man's mouth. You what? I just don't
find any of these men attractive. I will forever be safe. She's
in your man's mouth. I in your man's mouth and you can't do about
it. I all over him. I I gave him my urine. I gave him my urine
and you're not going to do about it. You're not going to do about
it. Like in a jar as well or save for later. You're not going
to do about it. Come right now. Come right now and I'll I will
you up. I will.
Yeah. Drama 101, you're gone for a little bit. Okay. You can
come back in 30 minutes. You need to you need to go and think
about your life. So you got a 30-minute timeout. Good luck. Come
back later.
You I'm not reading it. Letting everyone on the internet. I in
your man's mouth and you can't do about it. So next time you
kiss him, taste my
That's gross and cold and gross and cold. Every every time Zena
is talking to Darius, just imagine.
Okay, imagine Darius's breath here. Okay, Zena's probably into
it. Imagine apparently also apparently Darius's head got shaved.
I might have to watch some highlights from the ice beside cuz
Darius is now
shaved like a monk or some [__] I don't know what
the Isn't there a Tekken character with that kind of hair?
Uh, Heihachi has way cooler hair than that. Yeah, you think of
Heihachi, but it's all up instead of down. Yeah, this is uh this
is crazy. I thought somebody made this with AI. I didn't think
this was real. I didn't think it was real at all. But yeah, Darius
is uh Yeah, he's having he's having a time. He's having a time.
Oh boy. Because I in his mouth, you
We're getting close, Kelly. We're one minute out from the end.
You can sit here and talk all this. For one, you're jealous because
I Your man. Was he quit? Darius quit. Oh, too bad. Apparently,
lots of Apparently, it's just like these events are just people
signing up to be tortured. Like, it's just fun ways to torture
people. It's uh it's brutal. In his mouth. Um you're jealous
because I get more attention for doing less than what you're
doing and you're mad about it because you realize, oh, I'm a
I'm a you are realizing you're a and you're a and I don't have
to do half the you do to get attention. says the person that
was just talking about drinking for Yeah. I don't I don't Well,
no, no, no. Somebody else loic. No, no, no. Not Not drinking.
Okay. The other person was drinking her. I don't Oh, is she at
a hotel for this in the middle of the night? Out here at a hotel
in the middle of the night. I don't have to do half the in order
to get what I Oh, also Zena does get like 500 viewers most of
the time. I've gotten I haven't had to give up. Nope. What have
you given up to get what you've gotten? And you want to sit here
and talk about, "Oh, you're more important than me and you get
more collabs than me." Yeah, because you give up your name one
person besides Darius that I You can't because you give up your
you give up everything to get a single crunk and life to get
your I don't know why I don't know why she would even say this.
Yeah, it's And realistically, I don't know about a whole bunch
of other people. Maybe. But like I've I haven't heard that accusation
from basically anybody but MC in prison forever as long as you
don't have a career. All right. You're going to you're going
to you're going to me. All right. Let's see it. Let's see it.
I'm willing to give up my life so you ain't have for the rest
of your life. You that's not acting like you have more to lose
than Zena or that you're better than Zena. You're like, "Yeah,
my life's so that if you me I'll just be happy knowing you went
to jail." That's But she's also like, "You're a loser. You suck.
Okay, I got to send one more clip of like apparently this is
in the middle of the night at the pool at her apartment and they
don't like that. Okay, hold on. Come on. You want to sit here
and say you're going to me and me? Let's make it happen. Let's
make it happen.
Hi.
Come on.
They come and say like probably, "Hey [__] it's the
middle of the night. The are you doing ranting out here in the
pool getting drunk? You're not even supposed to have alcohol
out here. What are you doing? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Embarrassing,
baby. This is This is the person who's gonna beat Zena and fight.
Okay. Security shows up. Imagine, it's not even the cops, but
security shows up. And this is the This is the energy switch.
Okay. Hi, bro. Imagine if Zena was doing this rant. The energy
she'd have for security if they showed up. Probably just the
building man. It might be the building manager. Yeah. That's
just very funny. It's just very funny. Damn. Okay. I got sent
a clip of Zena bear ming Darius.
Apparently this happened. You want to hurt the person that you
once loved? I went easy on you. I should have put on here. Oh,
they got steak odds for everybody. They got Darius and Shuy still
going, brother.
Serious. How much money did Darius get? Did Darius get money
to shave his head like this? Or did they do that to everybody?
Oh, they did it to everybody. Everybody's got goofy hairstyles.
Okay. It's supposed to be in your eye.
Oh boy. More or is that enough? All she does is cause pain to
your life. There is no benefit at all for you and her. Okay.
Thank you. Ice Poseidon coming in with like the voice of God
from above. Okay.
Darius. Darius. There is no benefit to either of you in this
relationship. Please listen. Please listen. Little do they know,
Darius. The voice was like, "Darius, Darius, Darius, Darius.
Darius, Darius, what are you doing? What are you do? I'm trying
to do a Destiny. I can't do it. Uh, high pitch, very fast speaking.
That would be the voice that Darius would listen to as if it
were God. Okay. How shallow is that cast of car characters for
Ice? Well, I think a lot of those people for Ice Poseidon like
they know that this was advertised as like basically torturing
people. Yeah. Ice does Kicker Keep where he wins every time.
Why would you enter his contest? He's a Okay. Uh, all right.
Spends the next two hours in pain. It's hilarious. Is it hilarious?
Maybe it is. It might be. Okay. Okay, we got the Aerys clip.
Oh, we got a couple things. If you're going to defend Denims
for 3 hours, it's time to walk the walk. What is this? And and
dislike the video. The Where's the Denim's defense for 3 hours?
Um, did I get linked to time stamp or Oh, no. I don't have to
watch this. I don't have to watch this because it was very kind
of Ethan Klein to point out that like she actually gave substantial
commentary the whole time. He pointed out all the time stamps.
You don't have to watch it. You can just go look at the lawsuit.
The lawsuit doesn't claim that she did not substantially react
to this. The lawsuit claims that her reaction, her commentary
was bad. That's what the lawsuit claims. Yeah, it's it's actually
just such garbage. It's very embarrassing for Ethan Klein and
all involved. Yes, Ethan deceptively edited the video to make
it look like Denim's chair reacted to that whole thing when that
was not the case. Is Discord React still scuffed? Is Discord
React still? Oh, I have no idea. I can check it in a little bit.
Okay. Uh Ry, they're both a part of the lawsuit, but he is suing
for both, right? He is suing for both. And his the way he frames
it in his video as if this is ish is as if it's about the content
nuke when it's not. But there's also all of the commentary from
the content nuke, the things he disagrees with, that's all in
the in the lawsuit as well. The the stream is probably only there
so that he could frame it this way. That's actually he probably
realized that when he was trying to frame it, it actually goes
really poorly for him. So, he registered the stream to go, "Oh,
I want to include the chair part." That's that seems like the
most likely option to me. Possibly something different, but I
don't see what else. He's not suing anybody else or he's uh What
is he not doing? He's like he's he didn't need that for anybody
else, right? I'm I'm pretty confident that's the case. Would
love to see if anybody ever asks him that. Okay. All right. All
right. All right. Darius dropped out today. Yeah, I heard that
that Darius dropped out today. Are we watching? Are we watching?
Um
I I'm trying to get Aristocracy to come on stream to talk about
stuff to Okay, so I don't know. I don't know if I want to watch
this and like totally disagree if it's like hyperdefensive of
uh of Ethan Klein. I Well, also aggression against Israel. Yeah.
No, I'm not going to watch that if it's about Israel. Nope. Nope.
Nope. Are we just sticking our head in the sand, are we? Uh no,
that's going to be about
What are you What are you going to do when they actually come
on stream and then you disagree? Uh, disagree politely. So, you
can't disagree politely on stream without them here. No. What
do you mean no? You could only be an Because it's going to say
things that I'm going to be like, this is insane to me. Um, the
joke that I This is It's going to feel insane. It's going to
feel I and I Friday night. Listen, I've had I've I've looked
at Aerys's commentary before and I I'm like, this is not realistic.
I don't think this is realistic at all. I I'm just wondering
why you have
reserve when someone's in the room, but you can't have the reserve
when they're not here. It's like, can't you just pretend they're
here? If that's what you're worried about, I can I can direct
I can like ask questions. When I can't ask questions and they
keep compounding their statements over and over again, that's
where it gets frustrating. Right? If I could if she like made
an assertion, I could immediately pause her and go like, "Hey,
wait, wait, wait, wait. Can we walk through that?" Then it's
different, right? But if I'm going to have to watch her like
walk through things over and over and over again.
True. Uh if I have to like listen to her talk about and I know
what it's going to be about cuz it's about like anti-semitism
in Canada which I'm just like brother sister what are we doing?
What are we doing? Was um they were so grateful that their um
their neighbor um their neighbor was not a Zionist because otherwise
they would be trying to steal their water and their land. Everyone
laughed at that. Oh,
wait. What? Um, the joke that I heard Friday night was um they
were so grateful that joke she heard Friday night is in Eastern
and Western Canada very very different.
Uh, yep. Yep. Not that different. Their um their neighbor um
their neighbor was not a Zionist because otherwise they would
be trying to steal their water and their land. Everyone laughed
at that. Mention literally neighbor. So yeah for do you know
what it Yeah. I I'm sorry. I don't really expect Muslims to uh
I don't really expect Muslims to differentiate there to be honest
like at the current was like to watch hostages friends of my
family members and stuff um on videos like around um being stored
in areas with bags that have Wait, she watched videos of her
family members being held hostage by labels on organizations
I'd raised money for. That's gonna that mean
I okay I would friends of family members
where bags from aid organizations okay I would say probably you
don't know what happened with the aid from those organizations
if it was stolen it's all about this it's like right like we
don't know what happened with the aid could be stolen from those
organizations you don't know and then it's just bags right it
could be taken from anywhere I don't know that that means like
fundraising for Palestine is always bad and Um, but I need to
get out. I need to get out of my situation. It's not good. It's
really bad, you know. So, I don't have much of a choice. Um,
and I can't People are like, "Oh, like leave leave Canada." It's
like, "Where do you want me to go?" My other option, first of
all, I She's saying her situation in Canada is bad.
Yes. Because of one joke and something to do with aid that didn't
happen in Canada, I assume.
Or what was that then? Uh, I think she's she basically feels
like it's incred like Canada is
disgustingly anti-Semitic. I believe because of one joke and
one issue
crimes like I think one of the things that happened around her
was people people might have painted like swastikas on like a
bagel shop or something. I saw a post about that. There's been
like some things where people might have been like attacked on
some basis, but it's like it's not really any different than
anywhere else in terms of like you probably have about an equal
chance of being hate crimes for being just about anything. I
just I don't believe that are at like some sort of like out they're
not at like some insanely outlying position where they're way
way more likely to be hate crime in some way. I just don't believe
that. Right. Like I'm sorry. Who who would you rather be in Canada?
Question for the class, for everybody here. Would you rather
be an Indian man in Canada or a Jewish female in Canada? That's
not close to me. That's not remotely close. I know which one
I'd pick every single day of the week. Okay. It's not close at
all. Okay. In terms of the amount of like racism and and uh prejudice
you're going to face, it's not close. mostly from you. No, not
from me. I'm just saying that like Indian people get like a ton
of hate here and that's I would be way more concerned. Now you
could argue that they're a way bigger block so they maybe have
some groups they could live in but um yeah and then just to begin
with on a base level Canada's like the most racially accepting
place on earth. Okay, I'm sorry. Just on a base level Canada
is like so more acce so much more accepting than basically anywhere
else on the planet. It's crazy. I just refuse to believe that
these people like go outside of their house enough for this to
be a legitimate problem. Also, Canada's mostly like ice. Like,
I don't know. Like, what's the likelihood you're really going
to run into someone that's like a problem? It's not mostly ice
where she lives. It is mostly ice. Cold and I don't know. You're
a weird ass country.
Yeah. Yeah. Which way? Um, and I can't penguins. Uh,
aren't penguins only at the South Pole? Damn, that sucks. You're
cold. Penguins at the North Pole. I actually don't know. I have
no clue. What do you have at the North Pole? Do you have anything
cool? Um I mean polar bears. Yeah, which aren't cool. They're
not cool. Polar bears are psychotic. There are communities where
like they have to be aware of polar bears. Polar bears are crazy.
Polar bears have no penguins that eat them all. Polar bears are
capable of pattern matching in a way that like most other predatory
animals are not. Okay. land predatory animals. Polar bears will
literally stalk humans,
figure out their schedule, and then try to ambush them in places
where they're alone. Like, if you take a every morning at 8:00
a.m. and you walk out to a like a outhouse that's there, a polar
bear will be waiting there to ambush you at like 8:00 a.m. Like,
they will know if I go about this time, I will I will find them
there. And they also don't try to like uh they I think they also
torture their prey. They also just for fun. Like basically if
you run into a polar bear, it will kill you. Polar bears just
operate on like I you no threat to me. I you more food for me.
I kill you, nothing bad happens to me. I you automatic. I can
kill anything. If I see you, I kill you. That's like the That's
what polar bears operate on. Okay. It's nuts. You don't want
to be Polar bears are one of the few animals that regularly stalk
humans as prey and they're hyperaggressive in general. Yes, exactly.
Also, uh there's like a joke about polar bears that like what
do you do if you run into a polar bear in the wild, uh you take
your clothes off and you start running and you hope that you
can freeze to death before it catches you.
Yeah, polar bear is not cool, dude. Okay. Have you seen an arctic
fox? They're really cute. I just Googled animals that are in
the North Pole. Uh there's probably
All right. Uh back to Aerys. Let's see what she's about. She's
about to highlight like some of the reasons she's leaving. good.
It's really bad, you know. So, I don't have much of a choice.
Um, and I can't People are like, "Oh, like leave leave Canada."
It's like, "Where do you want me to go?" My other options, like,
first of all, I can't go to America. So, the only other option
really be like is moving to Israel. And um, while that's tempting,
I don't know if I want to go without my parents, right? And my
parents might come to be honest. My parents just had almost like
an almost pogram in their neighborhood. Was this video? Oh, before
Iran bombed back. So, if I had to guess, this would be shortly
after October 7th. Probably like 2 to 3 months after October
7th, but I don't know for sure. Riyle, you clipped it. Where?
When is it from? I just I would imagine it's not like super recent.
I'd imagine it's an older VOD cuz I remember her talking about
moving months ago. One year ago. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Two weeks
ago. And And my mom had not been believing anti-semitism was
a real thing anymore and stuff. And like now she suddenly she
was like horrified and now she's like maybe we should go back.
Yeah, it's hell on earth. Well, can we do we know what the almost
pilgrim was? I would love to know. Why did go to cit? I I don't
trust testimony about any of this. Um I just thought it was strange.
Oh, you're talking about like on vacation and like why does No,
like a bunch of them or when they were getting bombed a bunch
of them gone on boats and left a creep. Um, I guess cuz you could,
it's one of the places you could take a boat to. It's like right
there, right off the coast. Just seems weird, huh? Uh, I Googled
it. It was a Palestine protest. Okay. Um, yeah, Laticious Gamer.
I just I think she got I think she was just very biased after
October 7th, which I can kind of understand, but like then I'm
going to criticize basically like I would need to see proof of
what was going on here. That's all. That's my life right now.
Like right now, literally this second I'm negotiating for an
apartment. People will be like, "Oh, this this person was canceled
because they were critical of Israel." It's like, you know what
critical of Israel meant? It meant literally denying the rights
of Israeli women. That's not crit Okay, that's not critical of
the government of Israel. Okay, that's called being a bigot and
an
so much and criticize everything that needs um
maybe I don't What is that relevant to that somebody complained?
It sounds like somebody got cancelled or something for for like
what you could you could say they're bigoted opinions, right?
You're going to deny because it's Israelis, right? You could
say they're bigoted opinions. Maybe bigoted nationality, but
they're bigoted opinions, right? But it sounds like they got
cancelceled. It sounds like the levers of society work perfectly
there. Criticism. Yeah, I have a side 100% because I'm Israeli,
right? Cuz I just at the end of the day, I don't want my family
to get killed. Um but I don't expect anyone else to um got to
make that necklace. Yeah. Okay. So I I'm So the way I operate
in Toronto is I I'm on what I call historic. This is the real
historical term from Portugal, right? Oh god. It's going to be
it's going to be something about blending in in a society that
is like hateful towards them that would like hate crime them,
right? And she's doing that in Toronto, Canada. Is I am a um
a crypto in the city. So I wear a ring that says Hebrew and no
one She got a ring. She got a necklace with a cold storage wallet
on it. Okay. They call her a crypto. Else understands what it
says. And uh and I also have uh I I have a bracelet that I'll
like wear underneath my sweaters or something like that. But
I hide it. I hide it because I know someone who on their way
to university two 3 weeks ago, they're on the subway and he's
wearing they're on the subway in Toronto. He's wearing a star.
Just a normal. It's not. Now here's the thing.
I would if I were if I were living in Toronto, I would probably
right after October 7th not wear like Stars of David. I would
probably go like, you know what? Um, it's not worth the hassle.
It's not cuz I think they're going to get attacked. It's not
cuz I think they're going to get punched in the face. It's just
I think if there's somebody who's on the other side, let's say
there's a Palestinian living in Toronto and they see that and
they come to fight with you, argue with you, right? I would expect
it to go to words and I just wouldn't want that at all. I just
wouldn't care for that, right? But like it's not like I would
think I'm going to get like killed or that I think I'm going
to get like some form of insane harassment. I I'm just like yeah
I there's like emotions are running really high. Yeah. I don't
want to I don't want to be involved right now. Now should people
have to hide like that? No. But I would expect that if you somehow
had the demographics flipped you just much more likely to run
into I believe Muslims than
in Canada. Right. If the demographics were flipped I'd feel the
same way. I just wouldn't want to get into arguments. You should
have pride in being people are the best. Well, I'm not I'm Canadian.
I'd wear a Canadian flag, but I also live in Canada. Not nothing
Israeli on his shirt. Not that that would justify it either.
And he's just walking around a shirt. Not that that would justify
it. Not nothing Israeli on his shirt. Wait, wasn't it a Star
of David? On the subway. And he's wearing They're on the subway
in Toronto. He's wearing a star. Just a normal like a necklace.
A Star of David. A Star of David. Like the the symbol on the
flag of Israel. I I hope you understand that if you're like I'm
super proud to be you're going to get conflated with you're going
to be conflated with people who are Zionist especially after
that like attack. Yeah. Unfortunately that's just a totally reasonable
conflation to make like it's a reasonable conflation to make
and not only that it's like an especially
it's an especially expected conflation to be made right after
October 7th. Right. Also I don't think this would be October
7th. This would be like uh like weeks after the ground operation,
right? It sounds like I'm saying this is like after October 7th
as in like people were mad at for getting terrorist attacked.
No, it was it was the response after weeks or months of the response,
right? It was not it was not just October 7th alone. I should
be very clear on that. It's not nothing Israeli on his shirt.
Not that that would justify it either. He's just walking around.
Um and this very religious Muslim guy kind of comes up to him
and just starts praying right in front of him. It's like, okay,
you know, whatever. This is a pug. Okay. This Muslim guy walked
up and started praying in front of me. This son of a [__]
Everyone's there's a lot of religious people in Toronto. Have
fun. Um and then he starts looking at his um the star and then
he starts you yelling about the gods and children. We're in like
the guy I know's face and he just starts yelling him and then
he starts chasing him down the like down the cart and the guy's
like running and eventually guy finds this like these Brazilian
soccer players that defend him. Thank God for Brazilian soccer.
Did they Did they know the break dancing fighting? Did they Did
they do capoera? The Brazilian soccer players
do like windmills on the ground and defending this Jew. Sounds
like the most story. I don't know. Sounds like a cartoon. I don't
Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on. Hey, anti-semite.
Not so fast. Anti-semite. Not so fast.
Not so fast, anti-semite. Not today.
Not today. Absolutely not today.
Ah Jesus.
What is that? That is uh Full of Hell. Gifted sub to Shabbite.
Thank you very much. Full of hell. Appreciate it, buddy. Appreciate
it. Super cool. Super cool Brazilian guys who started defending
me. Oh, okay. This is, by the way, this is like way too exhausting
to actually do. These guys are supposed to be like experts and
they're not even remotely close to like going at fighting speed.
How is any of this supposed to hit somebody or be like a fighting
technique? It seems more like an art form. I don't know. Whatever.
Whatever. It's fine. Okay, we're back to back to the video. Players,
the true defenders. That was a crazy situation. So, yeah, it's
wild, man. So, yeah, I'm not So, basically something openly LGBT
people experience all the time from super religious people. Yes.
Yeah, that's true. Right. If you like literally I would expect
this to happen in some places. If you like kissed your if you
were a man and you kissed your boyfriend in public, I'd expect
there's a decent chance you get like a lecture from some religious
person, that's like probably wrong, but women trying to get an
abortion with the aggressive praying
clinics. Yeah, psychos. Yep. Yep. Yep. Going to wear my dad's
like, "Oh, you should be proud. You should be proud. You should
wear your juice." It's like, okay, I'm not What? Also, am I crazy
or do most Jewish people call it a G star? Is that just an Is
that what Jewish people call a star of David? A star? You should
wear your G star. You're a You're a proud Jew. You should wear
your star. I I will I just be your painting.
Reban Ruben donated $3
an AI meme in stream chat for you. D. Okay, thank you, Reuben.
Ruben, I'll check that out after this video or remind me in chat
as well. Not going to be proud after I'm dead. So, no, I just
I'm sorry. That story right there is like the Muslim guy started
praying and and yelling about gods and children or something,
which I totally believe. I believe that could happen, but then
started chasing him down the street for no reason. Why didn't
he just get aggressive right off the bat? Why did he start so
passive? I actually don't understand. I'm going to cover it up.
Every here who is willing to be I I'm just saying that like he
I assume he would get aggressive and talk to the guy directly
right off the bat if it wasn't them having a back and forth.
totally out and proud. Good. I admire you. I admire your bravery,
you know, um, all of that kind of stuff. But, you know, I'm afraid
of anti-semites, man. I'm afraid especially that they I feel
like they could like murder me and then they just go tweet and
be like, "Oh, I just murdered a Zionist."
That's not funny. That's not funny. That's not funny. That's
not funny. I shouldn't laugh. That's not funny. Ever happened
once in Canada?
I don't I've never heard of it. I it like if it did if it did
I would imagine it was like somebody who's widely denounced and
like like a psycho like a literally somebody having like a a
psychotic break, right? If something like that I don't think
they'd be going to brag about it. Yeah, I've never and like Yeah,
I've never heard about this. Nothing like this.
It's like we've Oh,
I think I think she would have gone past a lot of this now. What's
the violent crime rate in Toronto or wherever she is? Uh it's
probably not that high. Like, man, I don't I really actually
don't know. Yeah, I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I
don't know what's happening. Yeah, it's Canada. Like, no. Nobody's
murder murdering somebody and then saying I just did that. That's
just not a thing. That's not a thing anywhere.
Uh, true. Be very vic. Yes, you can tell. Is this maybe a little
group that doesn't go out that much? is it's like, bro, a sober
Muslim holy person, like a solo a sober religious Muslim person
was chasing them. It wasn't even a crackhead with like a needle
chasing you down the street. Dude, you got the premium experience
right there. Okay, I'll take the I'll take the hyperreligious
Muslim guy any day of the week over the average crackhead in
Canada. Okay, the average methhead, bro. I walk down I walk I
walk downtown where I live, bro. It's crazy. Okay, you just and
you have to do this thing. You have to do this like this like
psychic domination thing where like you have to not show that
you're bothered by them. Okay, when they start yelling insane
at you, you have to not show you're bothered by them, right?
You have to keep walking and like not quite acknowledge them,
but not totally ignore them or like pull away from them. You
just have to be like, "Yeah, you keep pushing." Exactly. You
like you Oh, sorry. Full of hell is talking about religious people.
But the tactics apply to both religious people who are yelling
at you and methheads who are yelling at you or crackheads who
are yelling at you. Okay? You just like you need to play this
game where it's like I'm not scared of you. You're just kind
of like you're slightly annoying but not so annoying that I want
to offend you. Okay? Cuz I swear to God if you get people who
like turn the other way, they'll they pick that up instantly.
Okay? That's like that's like fear to like a crackhead is like
sound to something from um oh what's the what's the John Kuzinski
movie? Quiet place. Okay. It's like like they they have like
the sensors. They will they'll pick that up instantly and they
will sprint at you. It's crazy. All right. And then everyone
would love them. There has been like this mass exodus from a
lot of leftist spaces. Oh my god. Just imagine how it is for
gay. Go on the subreddit gay. Okay. And like listen to their
stories. It's awful. Um, and they're all voting conservative.
I I would just love to know for those gays, what do they get
more hate for? Being gay or being queen
not cool, not funny, not okay. Uh, rampant rampant rampant homophobia
in this chat right now. You guys all need to settle down. Stop.
Stop. Stop. Because it's like even like my trans friends like
they would ra rather lose some of their trans rights and vote
conservative than like have literal pilgrims in their neighborhood
and their family like destroyed. Like there's priorities. It's
so sad to see that there's still so much anti-semitism in the
world today. Yeah. Yeah. For sure. Um but you know what this
is what the original Zionist predicted that there would be times
when that there's a cycle of hatred. Right. If you read the original
Zionist literature that uh that will do very badly and the world
loves dead like when die then they're like oh we feel bad for
you. Um, and then sorry. Oh, that's not funny. That's not funny.
That's not funny. But also, that is like a victim complex on
like a level we have no idea.
And they start doing well. Um, the minute they start doing well,
jealousy forms and then they become like I would say before 5
years ago, it was almost a golden age of in America and Canada
and the West like a golden age. um to the point where we were
almost be a golden age where like literally any comment about
any comment would get you like banned and canceled from everything.
Okay.
You you have negative comments, negative thoughts about the state
of Israel. Uh yeah. No, no, no. You don't get to I can't I can't,
bro. I I'm going to push too far. Okay. Cuz as we all know, light
anti-semitism tends to be very funny and a form of exposure therapy
for certain people. Okay. And I just I'm going to push too far
and it's going to get reallyed up. I don't I'm not actually anti-semitic.
I swear being treated like we are white. Dioenes, thank you so
much for subscribing, but you just broke the rules. You broke
the rules. I'll have to pay the Timmy tax. So I I don't think
Aerys I don't think Aerys is quite this I don't think she looks
at it the same way anymore. She might she's still like aligned
with uh Israel. I think she still feels like get um outsized
hatred in the West, but I don't think she's quite at like this
stage anymore. Uh and but naturally when Jews start doing well
uh we become the perfect because we're such a minority there's
a bunch of reasons we become like the perfect um scapegoat. And
such a good example of this is how like leftists make the Palestine
Israel issue into an everything issue. Now you can be extremely
pro at Palestine extremely anti-Israel and that's does not mean
you're an anti-semite. Not not I don't believe that at all. Um,
especially if you're connected personally to it, like as like
a Palestinian or something, like of course I totally get that,
but Okay. So, what does she think the religious guy was? Uh,
but when you see comments like we won't have all rights, no one
will have rights until Palestinians have rights or like or like
that's it was a clip, but like Uh-huh. Okay.
Um, the joke that wait ah why did this just reset? What the or
like the Israel issue is an environmental issue. A bunch of reasons.
we become like the perfect um scapegoat. And such a good example
of this is how like leftists make the
Palestine Israel issue. We were a little before the in America
and Canada and the West like a golden age. Um to the point where
we were almost being treated like we were white. Dioynes, thank
you. So
you were being treated like you were white. That's that's literally
like literally nobody knows most people are especially in Canada.
They'll never know you're in Canada, unless you outright tell
people because you just look white and there are a bunch of white
people and not that many Jewish people. Like in America, there
are enough people, especially in some cities, that they might
actually be able to tell you're, right? In Canada, they will
never know you're unless you point that out yourself. Yeah. I
mean, this is the whole point of her like having to wear her
like star or whatever, right? To show pride or whatever. Like
they you are just white. you would still be so much for subscribing.
But you just broke the rules. You broke the rules. I'll have
to pay the demi tax. So, uh, and but naturally when you start
doing well, uh, we become the perfect because we're such a minority.
There's a bunch of reasons. We become like the perfect um scapegoat.
And such a good example of this is how like leftists make the
Palestine Israel issue into an everything issue. Now, you can
be extremely pro at Palestine and extremely anti-Israel and that's
does not mean you're an anti-Semite. Not not I don't believe
that at all. Um especially if you're connected personally to
it like as like a Palestinian or something like so this is where
like I would expect that religious guy. But here she's like,
"Oh, somebody who's wearing a Star of David and no symbols of
Israel." And it's like, okay,
listen,
one might say that that is a tactical decision by the state of
Israel, right, to incorporate ideology so that Jews feel compelled
to defend and be a part of the state of Israel even if they're
not from that country, right? Like that's a conflation that's
going to happen. If I wear a maple leaf on my If I wear a maple
leaf on my backpack and I say a and I go around to a bunch of
places in the world, they're going to assume I'm Canadian. If
it's not the Canadian flag, can I just go, "Uh, excuse me. Did
you just assume I'm Canadian? You disgusting piece of What? What?
You just did you just assume I was Canadian because I have a
maple flag or sorry, I have a maple leaf on my backpack. I just
like the hockey team. I just like the hockey team. You're a piece
of course. I totally get that. But uh but when you see comments
like we won't have all rights, no one will have rights until
Palestinians have rights or like or like the No, Harmon, she
was she was talking about a story where a friend of hers, a religious
Muslim man approached a friend of hers who had a Star of David
of some kind, maybe on a shirt or something or a necklace, I
can't remember. And the guy stopped in front of him and started
praying. Well, yeah, we don't know. apparently started praying
in front of him and then started praying for guys and children
in front of him and then apparently chased the guy at the Star
of David thing down the street until some Brazilians some big
Brazilian soccer players defended him. Yep. Israel issues sounds
like something out of a Jackie Chan movie.
It's so stupid. I don't know what you're saying. Or like the
Israel issue is an environmental issue. It's a race issue. It's
a um gay issue. It's a this issue and they're that that's classic
scapegoating just with modern lefty language. But that is what
scapegoating is. It is saying that all of these problems. Wait,
I think the Israel issue I don't think it's like insane to feel
like the Israel issue is a race issue. The Israel issue, the
issue with Israel is if you support a country that is by definition
trying to be an ethnostate, you have to accept other people's
ability to do that when they feel threatened, right? Otherwise,
you're like, "Oh, no. only only these people are allowed to feel
threatened because of like the Holocaust. It like all has to
go back to the the Holocaust. So or because of this group that
just happens to be the only shade in the world. That's I mean
that's like the most classic scapegoating ever. I feel like some
people lose their collective minds when it comes and then I walked
home. I did my walk of shame home. Yeah. I and I broadly just
don't like I think if you accept that if a if a minority group
feels threatened um and they have a justified reason to be to
feel threatened that they're allowed to have like an ethnostate
if you accept that I think there's no reason to also argue that
you have to actually face prams or some kind of holocaust for
you to need that ethnostate right as soon as you say that that
fear of threat not not a persistent threat there is no active
holocaust happening right but that fear of a former threat is
enough to I think you've immediately given that every white supremacist
white supremacist in the white supremacist in the US is correct
in thinking that like their demographic is being replaced and
they will face like some sort of backlash for the crimes of white
people. I think you I think you give that all up to them. I think
that's true. Um it feels like it became cool to dunk on a lot
in leftist bases. Oh yeah, for sure. So and they literally said
not Zionist. So that's a um like joke. Shame. A what do you mean?
She said she did a walk of shame. I'm just wondering what that
looks like. Uh I don't know. Yeah, I don't know. Was about how
lucky they are to meet that aren't Zionist. Like that's like
what it was about. Um which was terrible abusing. Um Toronto's
anti-Semitic. I was raised in the North York. Did it get really
bad? Yes, it did. It did. It got really bad. And it was not like
this like 10 years ago. It was not like this 20 years ago. It's
gotten crazy. And by crazy, I mean there are multiple times a
week at schools. Okay, we finally have a harsh claim. There are
multiple times a week at schools in Toronto. Now, now I think
that has to be fake. That has to be false. There is no possible
way that that could be true. Now, could you could you find the
barest? So, in order for her to not like be basically like in
order for this to not be insane, you would have to find a week
where two happened. I feel like I don't even know about happening,
but I I don't live in Toronto, so maybe I wouldn't care about
them. I would definitely hear about like a pattern of at schools
or something. I I would just want to know what those are. Third
months at Toronto school. Okay, but what does this mean by Right?
I I need to know what this means by Does it mean like a gun went
off at some point in the direction of the school or around the
school or does it mean somebody was shot? And then does it have
to do with Judaism at all or is there for some reason like a
high crime high crime area around the school? So, third school
third school. Ah, third Jesus Christ. Sorry. I'm uh I took some
cold meds and I'm I think they're hitting me. third in months
at Toronto school government officials have to understand that
the time for thoughts and prayers is over stated CIA an agency
of Canadian federations JNS staff so this is jns.org I don't
know what js.org is, but it never mind. I do know what it is.
Okay. ID of air strike thwarts imminent terror attack in Janine.
Israel carries out air strike on West Bank City Janine. Oh, okay.
Uh-huh. Oh, how you tell the story
dude. Their advertisement gives away exactly what they are. Look
at this. Here's here's what the headline is. Israel carries out
air strike on West Bank City Janine.
How you tell the story matters. Here's our here's our title.
IDF air strike thwarts imminent terror attack in Janine. Yeah,
how you tell the story matters, guys. I definitely trust this
website. I definitely trust this. You'll have to you will have
to go and look at like what the police reports say on these incidents.
Yeah. I mean, if you're going to try and argue that you're more
impartial than the I'd like to see that. I don't think they're
arguing they're more impartial. I think they're openly saying
what they are. I think it's very clear what's going on. Uh Chris,
thank you for the raid. What What's up, Chris? What's up? How's
it going? Okay. A at B Shaya Mushka Elementary School on early
Friday morning, early on Friday morning marks the third time
the shots have been fired at the Shabbat girls school in Toronto
in recent months. One second. Okay. There was a at the school
on May 25th and another on October 12th on Yam Kapoor. So video
shows vehicle and at Toronto girls uh with suspect. Police released
footage of a dark-colored car with two individuals inside who
fired at the by So they fired at the elementary school causing
damage to the building but resulting in no injuries since it
was vacant at the time. Okay. At 4:50 a.m. So again, multiple
at schools every week. Okay. Middle of the night, nobody awake.
Fired shots in the direction of the school that caused damage
to the wall of the school. Now, is that a threat? Can that be
perceived as a threat? Yes. But that is not what we would call
like any kind of pogram. That is not anything like that. Okay?
It's not like that.
Um, it's not a nothing burger. It's not a nothing burger because
you can argue that this is absolutely
like a threat. It is a threat. It is a threat. It's not nothing.
Okay? It's not nothing. I don't want to I don't want to go ahead
and say that it's nothing. I just want to say the framing of
it where I was told multiple at schools that we all know what
that means right you're implying multiple school multiple people
shot kids dead there are no kids but I would say lucluse it is
a threat of violence yes it is saying hey [__] you
major
just $5
shalom as you can see chat there is a rampid pram going on in
Canada but when I conquer Canada it'll only be the ordinary school
shooting
Uh-huh. Listen again. Not what she said. She said multiple at
schools at schools every week. So, first of all, she said every
week. Okay. Who Who am I arguing with here? It was
uh someone said that's not what she said. Where was it? I missed
it.
You guys know exactly what I'm saying, which is why I'm saying
that obviously there's a threat of violence,
right? I'm willing to give you that and say it's obviously a
threat of violence
but well hey let's let's go back and listen. I don't want to
I don't want to
um which was terrible way different than it was it was not like
this like 10 years ago was not like this 20 years ago. It's gotten
crazy. And by crazy I mean there are multiple times a week at
schools. Multiple times a week at schools. So first of all, multiple
times a week is clearly false. Yes. Like very very clearly obviously
false. We are seeing over a period of a year three times which
is a lot and it's clearly a threat. But I'm I'm looking at this
as like these are people who are not escalating to violence.
Um and I I want to see examples of escalations to violence. That's
that's what I want to see because we're we're talking about
She said that basically somebody would and kill her and tweet
about it. I'm not say there's a massive step up from what she's
describing
to what is saying or to what the reality is, right? She's describing
something sorry step down. She's describing something insane
and is like clearly a massive step down from that. I'm not saying
that she can't feel scared. I'm not saying that she can't feel
like that's a threat. It is a threat. I'm saying that she is
in one of the safest place for in the world. I mean, unless she
goes to school, I don't think she needs to feel personally scared,
does she? Um, I mean, they aren't. Also, is she going to school
at 4:00 a.m.? I don't Yeah. Well, it seems like it's clearly
So, I think basically anybody looking at this would see this
as a you fire if I went and fired at like a like if there was
a Muslim girls boarding school and I went and fired shots at
the school, I think it would be reasonable to infer I'm making
a threat towards Muslim. There is some there's some anonymous
vague threat towards Muslims. Yes. But there's a difference between
feeling some level of concern and being actively scared
cuz one's like you're actually in a period of risk and the other
is just like oh this isn't good. Not really close. Yeah. And
I I would be careful not to describe it as multiple a week at
schools. Yeah. When it's like three in a year that did apparently
nothing. I wonder if any of these were a firearm discharge from
a car targeted this school at 4:05 a.m. on Yam Kapoor. These
are different ones, right? 4:50 a.m. So, this is clearly in the
middle of the night, somebody is going and firing shots at the
school, not intending to harm people, but intending to send some
kind of threat, right? To cause fear amongst people. Okay, she's
allowed to be concerned. Yes, concern's fine, but then you're
speculating. You have to add the parameters. What if your niece
or nephew was there? Is that the case? Obviously not because
she would have mentioned it cuz she said everything else. Yeah.
I I just think like it's so I don't want to misstate what it
is. It's clearly it is very very very clearly a threat to Jewish
people. An anonymous threat for somebody who's like too scared
to take any real action of their own, right? They're just like
they're they're clearly like a a coward who wants to be scared
but doesn't want to risk getting caught, doesn't want to make
any kind of statement, doesn't want to stand behind anything,
right? They're like a cowardly loser. So you can be you can be
like uh I think you can be upset about that, but I would worry
that if you give cowardly losers like that power over you, you
will just be very very unhappy in life because it costs them
nothing to make those threats and to remain anonymous. It it
goes the same with threats on the internet, right? If somebody
is anonymous, there's no weight behind their threats. They're
just totally anonymous. There's nothing behind that. Like I'm
not going to give somebody who is not risking anything to make
a threat power over me, right? Or or you could you would just
be scared for the rest of your life, especially if you're a public
figure of any kind. Anyway,
so now we know multiple
every week means three in a year. Okay. I mean, like literally
almost every other day, I'm hearing from a friend of an anti-Semitic
incident on the subway, on the street. Just Friday night, I was
at an event where the person who was talking was insanely anti-Semitic.
And when I say antis, I don't mean just anti-Israel. I mean they
literally were talking about they said the word they didn't they
didn't say the word Zionist, okay? And everyone laughed and was
like, I I would love I would love
if we could, you know, believe that if they said Zionist that
I'm sorry, Eris, I I'm just saying if they had said Zionist and
said these same things, I know for a fact you would still say
it was anti-semitism. I hate to I hate to just call that out,
but it would still be anti-semitism to you, right? Even if they
said Zionism. Now, let's see what they said. Are they criticisms
of the state of Israel or are they criticisms of the people?
And I had to walk out. I was like, am I is this 20 24? What world
am I in? It's crazy. Absolutely wild. But my psychoess still
wants to live. Three is a lot for Canada though, right? I thought
guns weren't a thing up there. No, I mean, so people don't do
outside of gangs, people don't do violence with guns that often,
but people do have guns. It's not very difficult to get a gun
in Canada. Well, sorry. It's not difficult. It's not like it's
not difficult as in um it's not like particularly like a high
bar. It's just like bureaucracy. You have to register. You have
to get a license. Yeah. People Well, I don't think Eastern Canada
I don't think like the Greater Toronto area has the same level
of guns as a lot of the rest of Canada, but um but like people
aren't using guns to carry out violence against civilians in
the same way. It's just not a pattern in Canada. There are blanket
bans on some of the more like high-capacity uh higher lethality
weapons as well. Like I don't think you're allowed to own an
AR-15 in Canada in like any case essentially. I think that's
just like autobanned in every case. So here because I don't really
have another option. Um Oh, I can talk about it. I just like
the problem is I don't know. Oh, I will say as well for people
who are willing to break the law, almost all,
as Jude points out, almost all crimes in Canada are done with
illegal guns. No, most most handguns are most handguns are either
illegal, only pis or I can't remember. So, a lot of pistols got
banned recently by Trudeau like two years ago. Before that, you
could literally only have your handgun out of your house if you
are going to a shooting range. Otherwise, you are literally you
have your uh you have your gun. It has to stay in your house.
If you have it out of your house and you're off the path between
a registered range that you've registered with the police and
you get caught with that gun, you are breaking the law. You are
okay.
That's like what you have to do with a handgun in Canada to maintain
a handgun license. Damn. I've never seen a handgun cuz they've
been banned in the UK for so long. They only have shotguns and
rifles.
Yeah. Yeah, the issue is we share a border with the US and it's
like a poorest border that you can get over pretty easily without
like tons and tons of inspection. And so realistically like there
are a lot of illegal guns in Canada and they do come over from
the US. If you're if you're like a criminal and you're trying
to buy illegal guns, you can buy illegal guns here. Yeah. Yep.
Yep. Yep. Know if I want to get that person canled because I
don't really believe Sure. Americans don't know that handguns
are the biggest violent offenses. They think AR-15s are the worst.
Well, the issue is that most of the time if somebody is going
on a spree, it's with an AR-15, a high-capacity, like high lethality
weapon, right? Like the the the high casualty count civilian
events, like the the mass events, I believe usually would be
carried out. So, when I say mass, I'm going to put a bar higher.
Seven or higher deaths in those cases where somebody is out to
like put everybody down, I think those are like AR-15s.
Now, obviously, I I would wonder where where it shakes out if
you get rid of all gang violence
because that's like most lethality from guns in the States. It's
just like pure gang violence. I'd wonder where it shakes out
if you get rid of all even cancel culture. So, I don't know if
like I want to like advertise to the whole world what happened
that night, too. I might say what I just looked up why we banned
handguns and I'm like, "Ah, yeah, that makes sense." Probably.
Yeah, it was a really bad don massacre.
Yeah, like 16 kids and then hurt a bunch of others as well. Jesus
hell. So, Aerys was just telling us about she she had comments
about at an event that she was at. She's not getting it seems
like she's not getting specific about anything about it. I just
like the problem is I don't know if I want to get that person
canled cuz I don't really believe in cancel culture. So, I don't
know if like I want to like advertise to the whole world what
happened that night too. I might say what happened and I'm just
not going to say who the person's name is, but uh it was someone
it was a comedian thinking that like and they were not doing
actual comedy. It was a comedian not doing actual comedy and
they talked about Jews. Bro,
what? She went to a comedy show and she was like, "They made
comments about that's up." I don't know what that symbol was.
I might say what happened and I'm just not going to say who the
person's name is, but uh it was someone it was a comedian thinking
that like and they were not doing actual comedy. I don't know
what that symbol was by the way if someone subscribed to my Patreon
or something like that. Um isn't Drake half Yes, he is. So, but
we don't claim him. Look at him. We don't claim him. What? What?
Uh
no protections for Drake. Okay, Drake, we're kicking you out
of the bomb shelters. Get out there. Tank a rocket for us. you,
Drake. All right, Drake, your up her ability to blend in with
the whites. All right, you also your kid is way too obvious.
You got to be Cooper. Um, but you know, it's fine. But yeah,
it was a comedian. It was a comedian that made the comments.
But the thing is is that I'm normally I'm a super I am an old
school girl. Do not do not come to me and say comedy was a thing
until it targeted a group I cared about. Do not come to me and
do this. Okay, this entire thing, people always do this. It was
funny until he went after a group I'm a part of. It was funny
until he started making fun of my people. Okay, it's so embarrassing.
This happened to so many white people when Dave Chappelle did
his jokes about the opioid epidemic. So many white people went,
"Uh, yeah, it was funny and now you you took it too far." Okay,
Dave Chappelle, you took it way too far. It's like, do you listen
to any of this guy's jokes from the '90s and 2000s with the crackheads
in black communities? Do you see him making fun of his own community
in this exact way? And he's literally doing he's just recycling
the same jokes on white people. And you're like, actually, this
is way too far. I don't approve this. This is unacceptable. This
unacceptable.
And she's she's doing it right now. She's being the uh the white
Chappelle. I am an old school girl when it comes to humor. Like
I'm a anti-SJW humor girl. I like I grew up playing video games.
I like my really dark runchy humor with the like the most up
jokes. I will laugh at a Holocaust joke. Okay, I will do So this
comedian was doing something worse than a Holocaust joke. What
was this comedian saying? Do that. I have no pride. But so I've
never been the What is this entire then? Don't wear your star
and just pretend to be white. What? This whole thing This whole
thing started for like you didn't want to feel like you had to
hide. Well, you don't have any pride in being just hydrogen start.
You're fine. Person who's gotten like offended by comedy before.
Like that's just not me. And but there is something that really
feels different when you know the person is uh by the way I really
Okay, I really hate to point this out. Oh, it's rough. You could
totally figure out comedians who were in Toronto on like the
weekend before this happened or like the week before this happened
and super narrow it down. Yeah. No, you could easily narrow this
down very, very, very easily if you wanted to. I'm not going
to, but you could very easily narrow it down. I could She said
all the lines, too. Listen, guys, I'm I love comedy and comedians
should be able to say whatever they want. But like, have you
considered that when they say this about a group I'm concerned
about that it's actually like racism or anti-semitism or religious
bigotry? Did guys, I listen I've laughed at Holocaust jokes before,
but that when they talked about how like people do this X, that
was really up. Okay, that was really up. Not a lot of comedians
in Canada if you could narrow it down. Well, it's somebody it's
probably somebody who was touring, right, bro? I don't
Yeah, I don't I don't get it. Um, the joke. Anyway, that was
cool. That was fun. Oh, man. Are we ready to go on to the Tom
Foolery stuff? I think we're
wakes up in the streams right
for a job clipboard in his hand while Kelly's just thinking his
head's poorly planned. I dropped 10 quid from JK.
If I could you see
all my homies hate
Enjoy the cream. Oh, Kelly Jean the angry British queen screaming.
Let me right through your screen. Got Kelly Range with Syndrome.
It's plain to see. Oh, now you know how it feels. Believe me,
I demand the popcorn jet
Are bags of milk real? She muses with a sigh. Why is Cherry so
small? As the moments fly, left for 3 hours, came back, nothing
changed. While Ethan's become the monster he once through. This
[__] is annoying. No punches she'll
We hate in a lot. Hateful
way.
That's her rule. Oh, Kelly G and an angry British queen screaming
you don't keep right through your screen. Got Kelly derangement
syndrome. It's plain to see. Oh my. Now you know how it feels.
Believe me. I demand the popcorn. Get you back, bro. Another
line in her fiery catalog.
How is it my fault? She'll exclaim there's a delay. You plunker.
It's part of the game.
is rare. We never stop. Says he will later then forgets the whole
coral. I'm going to doubt angrily. If you can't stand by your
words, then just let it be. She commands with a merry caddy on
a bed. The battle rages till dawn.
Oh, Kelly and an angry British queen screaming you don't right
through your screen. Got Kelly derangement syndrome. It's plain
to see. Have a laugh. Now you know how it feels. Believe me,
I demand the popcorn. Give you back another light in her fire.